but content is considered the worst
business you could go into your business
well my hobbies are content content
that's true but I never I never invest
in content businesses it's a little bit
of a only because I know it's so hard so
but you have a secret weapon
I believe you make this great content
but you don't need to monetize it off of
advertising do you correct this isn't it
this is just the beginning and that when
I worked at YouTube I watched these
teenagers in their bedrooms getting
millions and millions of views spending
not a lot of money to commit content
whereas Kraft or some random brand would
try to put up a video on YouTube get no
views like content was content equals
attention mm-hmm for this generation if
you're going to reach this generation
you have to likely reach them digitally
you're going to reach them digitally you
have to reach in through content so now
every brand has to be a media company
right so to be a media coming first and
to get that right and to understand
content how to reach people effectively
how to keep them engaged coming back to
you daily that's all of your acquisition
that's your marketing from there you can
convert them to whatever you want to do
right and for us you know we we always
new products and merchandising would be
interesting what we didn't expect was
paid content would also be another
revenue line so this was something that
came organically out of our users and
that they were like looking at these
cooking tutorials or crafting tutorials
and they're like I actually just don't
even know I want to like learn how to do
calligraphy but that sounds really
freaky to me I've never learned that I
live in the middle of Nebraska where do
I go like and so we started offering
online courses yeah and and the
computers in the space are like you know
you to me and Skillshare which are very
UGC oriented music generated content yes
yeah their platforms platforms yeah
quality will be variable the voice will
be variable rect pricing is all variable
we wanted to shoot you know young women
who were professionals in these
categories who could you know
authentically affiliate and talk to our
audience who where we shot them in our
Studios on colourful backdrops we
controlled the camera the zoo
is everything we control the product
experience so there's a whole classroom
experience we can talk to the teacher
and things like that and and it turns
out people are willing to pay for that
stuff where do they pay for that so I
want to take your cooking course twenty
to fifty dollars a class that's it
uh-huh Oh poor class for class so what
would a is it in a semester or they're
just one off everyone off classes so
there's like 101 - oh ends etc if you
want to like go down a deep so for
somebody who has money to spend 20 bucks
to take a cooking class nothing it's
nothing especially because when you take
these classes in person especially with
a lot of the instructors that we have
they're like hundred two hundred bucks
right a bargain it's a bargain for them
and on top of that we found that they
were like well cool I'm like super into
learn calligraphy or what are these pins
and inks and things I need and so we
started selling those products to them
as well and the super exceed all kind of
comes together and you're not scared of
charging for content that is freely
available on the web
correct because well the content is I
mean these classes are like over an hour
in length right like a video the
quality's way better it's the same thing
I saw at Pinterest like sure you can go
on YouTube and probably find all the
ways to create whatever yeah it's gonna
be kind of shoddy like yeah who knows if
the person is a real professional
teaching you you know yeah I don't know
you're paying for the brand proposition
and the value it provides you know if
it's Brit + Co it's going to be of a
certain level of quality correct and
you're not gonna let any schmuck get up
there and pretend they know what they're
talking about when they haven't done the
research yeah totally yeah it's not a
wiki where it's like yeah somebody has
given me advice and I think some of
those platforms are great right like I'm
you know you can learn a lot from the
internet yeah I generally would be
honest it's a lot of work to like we
curate it down ruling we're good we
curate the curriculum like we'll do they
actually need to know that step no like
let's skip that like you know we really
try to make it efficient so to summarize
free content pulls people into the paid
content paid content pulls them into hey
you might want to buy these products